la copie de langue des saintes aux
multiples et débilitants des mois après
l'infection chez nombre de patients en
principe rétabli deux kilomètres à
l'heure c'est à peu près la vitesse de
pointe des erreurs depuis trois mois
depuis qu'elle a attrapé lakovic 19
essoufflé épuisé incapable de se
concentrer
anne d'erreur souffre de ce qu'on
appelle la copie de longues ou le
syndrome post co bible des séquelles
hyper dur après que l'infection se soit
résorbée
un mal méconnu complexe on est comme
face à un nouveau territoire et on
n'était pas sûr de savoir exactement où
en est que les experts commencent à
peine à discerner c'est quelque chose où
on veut les données en temps réel pour
commencer à voir des pièces à ce jour
plus d'un million de canadiens ont
contracté lakovic 19 près de 24 mille en
sont morts
mais la grande majorité sont considérés
comme rétablie sauf que pour certains le
terme n'est pas tout à fait juste
j'ai deux vitesses arrêté puis trail
[Musique]
il y a six mois rien n'arrêtait and
bearer 44 ans mère de famille médecin
une famille aussi à l'hôpital du
sacré-coeur à montréal spécialisée en
soins palliatifs
de mon côté et effectivement j'ai eu la
même expérience que ce soit avec des
patients des clientèles en novembre elle
participait à ce webinaire un mois avant
d'attraper la coved au travail le
contraste avec son état actuel est
saisissant je m'essouffle à faire des
choses banales et je deviens fatigués
rapidement après son infection docteur
bearer croyait s'arrêter quelques jours
puis retourner auprès de ses patients
mais elle ne s'est jamais remise tu es
quelqu'un forum que toujours fait ces
choses sera posé de questions tu dois
mettre planifié avant de monter ou
descendre l'escalier
c'est certain
qu'il ya beaucoup qui tiennent le dr
bearer s'est tourné vers l'institut de
recherches cliniques de montréal
on y trouve l'une des rares cliniques du
pays consacrée aux séquelles de la coved
19 l'équipe dirigée par l'infectiologue
liana falconnet croule sous les demandes
de patients diminuer et inquiet c'est
pas uniquement des patients qui ont été
hospitalisés qui avaient des
complications de santé avant l'infection
covit qui se présente il peut voir des
passants qui étaient très fonctionnel
très performant avant l'infection
qu'elles se présentent des fois jusqu'à
un an post infections avec encore des
symptômes
ces symptômes sont très variés les plus
courants fatigue essoufflements perte
d'odorat mon mot tête mais aussi
difficultés de concentration douleurs
musculaires articulaires problèmes
gastro intestinaux anxiété entre autres
l'endocrinologue émirats base alors elle
participe à la clinique
tu es incroyable non de symptômes que
les gens peuvent présenter la liste des
symptômes s'allonge sans arrêt l'urgence
de soigner ces patients est de plus en
plus grande
selon diverses études jusqu'à un tiers
des adultes infectés par le sera sauvé 2
ressentent encore des symptômes
plusieurs mois plus tard comment ça va
aujourd'hui à qui on va commencer par
prendre votre pression artérielle
ça va à la clinique les factions comme
anne bearer subissent une batterie de
tests dans l'espoir de démêler
l'écheveau des symptômes et de traiter
ce qui peut l'être
si on prend l'exemple de la fatigue on
regarderait est ce qu'il ya de l'animé
est ce que il ya on a un déficit
thyroïdiens ou un problème avec les
glandes surrénales yens ou peut-être des
carrément un problème pulmonaire ou
cardiaque alors et même des fois
d'autres infections
il faut pas juste penser à couvrir mais
garder quand même un esprit assez large
selon les symptômes
qu'est ce qui pourrait expliquer ce
symptôme parmi ce que surveille les
médecins il y à aussi la glycémie
le diabète est un facteur de risque de
développer une forme grave de lakovic 19
mais ce n'est pas tout ce qu'on voit
aussi c'est que les gens qui ont
développé la copie qu'ils n'avaient pas
de diabète préalable une fraction
importante développe le diabète est donc
ça suggère que l'acolyte peu précipité
l'apparition du diabète
la grande question c'est est-ce que ça
va être transitoire ou permanent
malheureusement pour plusieurs personnes
dont anne d'erreurs
rien ne peut expliquer ce qu'elles
subissent on a beaucoup d'hypothèses
mais pour l'instant comme la plupart des
tests sont normaux ça ne donne pas une
réponse
ce filet cherche aussi des réponses
sa famille a attrapé la coved 9 en
octobre
de ses huit enfants ressentent encore
des symptômes comme la plupart des
jeunes charles 13 ans a été peu malade
pendant son infection mais quand il a
repris le chemin de l'école
son état s'est dégradé quand kiri 20
minutes l'école soir pour y rentrer dans
la maison puis ça m'offre à piller des
bruns mais blanc comme un drogué des ans
ce soir il se tenait à la poitrine et
dit maman mon café mal il y avait mal à
la poitrine y avait des palpitations il
était soufflé au moindre effort mais il
n'a pas d'histoire il y avait des
tremblements c'est comme si c'est encore
la vesle hanche et même si les cas sont
rares les enfants ne seraient pas
épargnés par la codi de l'ong
charles a passé toutes sortes de tests
qui pour l'instant n'ont pas pu élucider
ce qui lui arrive
son état s'est quand même amélioré au
fil des mois
lui et sa soeur qui a des symptômes plus
légers sont maintenant suivis à la
clinique post qu'ovide de la pneumologue
s'est menti à l'hôpital sainte justine
on ne crée cette clinique vraiment dans
le but de répondre à un besoin de ces
familles ont besoin clinique laissé
femme ils sont malgré que les
investigations ont été beaucoup normale
en général deux normales tant au niveau
pulmonaire qu'au niveau cardiaque au
niveau des prises de sang et il demeure
que ses enfants sont affectés sont
limitées dans la vie de tous les jours
par ces symptômes
en plus des symptômes physiques
la docteure ti s'intéresse à la santé
psychologique de ces jeunes patients
quand un peuple est ce que ils se sont
fait rire d'eux une course qu'ils ont eu
la copie de la somatisation est-ce
qu'ils sont plus stressés parce qu'il y
trop y sont plus capables de performer
comme avant je pense que quand même il
se faire le qui peuvent contribuer à la
persistance des symptômes mais je veux
pas non plus mettre tous ses symptômes
sur le dos de la psychologie de la santé
mentale jusqu'à temps qu'on sache c'est
quoi qui est derrière tout ça
ailleurs dans le binntal le
microbiologiste allait moreau lui voit
dans la coved longue des similitudes
avec une autre maladie méconnue
l'encéphalomyélite myalgique aussi
appelée syndrome de fatigue chronique
une maladie souvent associée à des
infections et qui provoquent de grandes
fatigues les difficultés de
concentration tachycardie troubles du
sommeil
l'ensemble de ces facteurs là on les
retrouve malheureusement de plus en plus
c'est des gens atteints du coc vite de
19 selon les chercheurs ont mis au point
un test un peu particulier les
participants sont équipés d'un brassard
qui leur sert le bras chez des gens
atteints d'encéphalomyélite myalgique
cette pression suffit à provoquer un des
principaux symptômes de la maladie
le malaise après effort le malaise après
fort et survient lorsque
une personne atteinte d'encéphalomyélite
va faire l'effort physique minimes où un
effort cognitif par exemple compléter un
questionnaire et qui va les amener à
chuter donc avoir vraiment une rechute
importante de leurs symptômes
au point de devoir se reposer presque
pendant plusieurs jours même dans
certains cas plusieurs semaines cette
rechute est mesuré par des tests
cognitifs et l'activité cérébrale des
participants depuis quelques semaines
les chercheurs font passer ces tests à
disons qu'ils ont eue là qu'ovide aller
mort ou ne serais pas surpris que
certains développent une forme chronique
de la maladie les infections précédente
avec d'autres chorales au virus donc on
parle du strass et du mars au moyen
orient aussi montré en 30 à 50% des gens
qui étaient infectées ont développé les
symptômes qui ressemble de façon très
similaire à l'encéphalomyélite magique
et ce même trois ans après leur
infection par ces coronavirus l'équipe
d'alain moreau tentent d'identifier chez
les gens atteints des molécules
révélatrice de la maladie des marqueurs
qui permettraient de préciser qui est à
risque de la développer et à terme de
trouver des traitements avec la colle et
19 ses recherches lui apparaissent de
plus en plus pressante
c'est peut-être vous savez l'image
l'iceberg ou même s'il ya eu beaucoup de
jeunes dans la partie immergée qui sont
atteints de la comédie 19 il ya encore
plus de gens qui sont à risque de
développer des séquelles alors qu'on
pensait qu'il s'en était bien sorti
à l'hôpital sainte justine
comme à l'institut de recherches
cliniques de montréal des échantillons
prélevés chez les patients sont
conservés pour des recherches plus
poussées
au delà de traiter les séquelles on
voudrait comprendre ce qui peut les
causes est présentement on ne le sait
pas et hongrie bay il ya des hypothèses
il ya des chercheurs qu'ils ont émis
l'hypothèse que pat est que le virus
triste en dornier dans certaines places
du corps et c'est ce qui cause des
symptômes qui persistent ça se peut que
ça soit ça autres suspects la réaction
inflammatoire provoquée par le virus
pendant la phase aiguë de la maladie qui
pourrait régler certaines fonctions de
l'organisme mais ça reste à démontrer
on va essayer d'avoir une réflexion plus
générale traiter le symptôme est
peut-être avoir quelque chose d'essayer
de trouver un espèce de cause commune à
tous ces symptômes que les gens ou ou
encore une cause commune à plusieurs de
ces symptômes et de proposer un
traitement plus en amont qui a très très
la cause et non pas juste les symptômes
que les gens c'est pour ça qu'on a conçu
ce projet c'est pour commencer à démêler
ce nul avec des questionnaires avec des
prélèvements
je suis pas satisfait personnellement de
juste donner une étiquette à une maladie
puis dire or c'est juste ça c'est un
pêle-mêle de choses puis da titre si
juste si pour cette raison là que je
suis médecin et chercheur parce que je
veux de j'y pense
[Musique]
ce grand verre et d'un petit pas dans la
bonne direction pour cindy nos pop et
ouais madame nous attraper la copie de
19 en mars 2020 comme près de 60% des
gens infectés
elle a perdu l'odorat et le goût qui
l'accompagnent si je prenais un café ça
goûte est vraiment l'eau si je prenais
un jus d'orange à goûter l'eau je
mangeais ça coûtait rien tout goûté
comme du riz blal disparu le plaisir de
manger pour cette gourmande autoproclamé
fini aussi le système d'alarmé qui est
censé être notre odorat
mais en fait trouvé que ça sentait
l'essence dans maison je pense quelqu'un
avait laissé la porte de garage ouverte
sa montée dans maison jamais rien sans
titre
non je m'accroche pas au sommet c'est
que oui ça ce n'est pas que sur la
sécurité
la perte d'odorat est l'une des
séquelles les plus fréquentes de lakovic
[Musique]
dans ce laboratoire de l'université du
québec à trois rivières
on étudie les troubles affectifs et
leurs liens avec le cerveau l'équipe de
johannes fanelli a sondé près de 1000
travailleurs de la santé affectée par le
virus pour évaluer leurs capacités
olfactives jusqu'à cinq mois après
l'infection
j'ai cinquante pour cent des
participants l'odorat n'était pas encore
revenu à la normale à ce qu'il était
avant l'infection eu quand même un
chiffre énorme à mon avis 50% c'est pas
encore revenue à la normale
mais parmi eux 20 % qu'il n'atteindrait
vert de l'odorat cinq mois après la
coved quand il infecte la muqueuse du
nez le virus attaque des cellules qui
soutiennent les neurones olfactifs ces
cellules meurent puis les neurones à
leur tour les signaux provoquée par les
odeurs ne peuvent donc plus se rendre
correctement au cerveau pour cindy no ça
a duré plusieurs mois puis des arômes
sont revenus peu à peu mais pas toujours
pour le mieux quand je buvais du vin
rouge si on remonte à l'été passé ça
goûte est vraiment le jus de torchon
certains parfums les coeurs les agrumes
mon goût de moisi
fini les fines herbes dans les petits
plats qu'elle aime cuisiner ça goûte
catch au niveau de moisson de fermenter
ça goûte la forêt le bourg en langage
d'experts ça s'appelle une part aux
semis un odorat déréglé dans la
prochaine étape de leur étude les
chercheurs veulent voir s'il pourrait
aider ceux dont le doha n'est pas
revenue à la normale
il envoie aux participants des flacons
rempli d'essence de rose d'orange
d'eucalyptus et de clous de girofle et
ce que nous allons inviter nos
participants de faire céder prendre une
fiole après l'autre d ouvrir et des s'en
tire avec une narine avec l'autre
narines avec les deux narines
l'important c'est vraiment ici des
descentes et d'essayer dé comprendre
qu'est ce qu'on s'en dé réfléchir sur
l'odeur faire ça avec tout les 4 odeurs
et répéter ça chaque matin chaque soir
et ensuite les verts pendant trois mois
et à la fin de ces trois mois
on pense que l'odorat va être meilleur
l'idée de cet entraînement c'est de
réparer le système olfactif ses neurones
peuvent se régénérer à partir de
cellules souches en exerçant son odorat
on pourrait favoriser cette régénération
et recréer le câblage entre le nez ils
servent ou le dorat déréglé pourrait
être le signe d'un début de rebond
branchements je pense que dans le cas
des personnes avec la cour vite mais
maintenant ça c'est mon impression
personnelle qui ont perdu l'odorat uno
d'horaire est venu mais maintenant il
souffre d'une part aux semis moi je
pense que c'est plutôt un signe positif
que ça va dans la bonne direction qui a
quelque chose qui se passe pour moi
c'est quand même c'est encourageant je
sens que je suis sur une bonne voie puis
donc si je suis patiente encore quelques
années j'espère retrouver 100% de mes
capacités
la réadaptation est l'une des pistes
explorées pour aider les patients qui
ont des symptômes persistants de lakovic
pour anne d'erreurs les choses
progressent
quoique très lentement pour retrouver
son souffle
elle se concentre sur sa respiration
puis ça peut être plein de gens de
réadaptation cardiaque pulmonaire voir
neurologiques
yatuu des circuits qu'il faut ré
entraîner même au niveau immunitaire
si on a à émettre des hypothèses sur
qu'est ce qui pourrait être une cause
sous jacente est ce que on a une
inflammation qui persistent
puis ça ça peut prendre différentes
formes alors il y aurait peut-être même
une rééducation immunitaire à faire des
circuits à ajuster réétablir qui se sont
souvent des processus qui prennent du
temps
en attendant de prendre du mieux de
tourbe erreur consacre le peu d'énergie
cayla a réclamé plus de ressources pour
ceux qui souffrent comme elle de kobe de
l'ong
avoir des rendez vous pour des tests pas
évident c'est sûr qu'il faut quelque
chose s'organisent pour qu'on puisse
prendre en charge tous les gens qui ont
des ses six duels
pour l'instant on compte à peine une
poignée de cliniques post co vide au
pays
je dirais qu actuellement on a à peu
près 10 fois plus de demandes que notre
capacité ça reste actuellement un projet
de recherche on perçoit une énorme
demande de soins et de prise en charge
et je pense que un ou une médecin de
famille sera encore plus perdus que nous
qui à bord dont ça avec un oeil de
chercheurs déjà peu aidé par commence à
émettre des lignes de conduite des
gueules angie ce ne serait ce que des
tests de base et qu'on pourrait
prescrire puis de les avoir a fait
rapidement ça c'est aussi
potentiellement un problème pour pouvoir
au moins etc sur des choses qui sont
facilement traitable ça c'est des choses
on peut travailler avec les
omnipraticiens avec les spécialistes
pour pouvoir au moins faire une certaine
prise en charge initiale au royaume uni
par exemple l'institut d'excellence en
santé a émis des directives pour aider
les cliniciens dans le suivi de l'aco
vide
au delà de la phase aiguë
on suggère notamment certains tests
sanguins des radiographies pulmonaires
des tests à l'effort de telles
recommandations n'existe pas encore au
canada
j'espère que dans quelques mois on sera
capable d'être plus cohérent avec ses
patients d'être capable peut-être de
disséquer d'aller orienter les gens vers
des thérapies et des prises en charges
qui sont plus pertinentes par rapport à
leurs symptômes
là on est un peu comme face à une
falaise qui va falloir qu'on grimpe lui
qu'on essaye de prendre un peu de
hauteur avec tous en une lente ascension
avec la guérison pour horizon
[Musique]